in what has become a weekend pattern
here in Hong Kong protest leaders spread
the word about an event through social
media and out they come starting with
small confrontations that escalate into
battles with police pulling out their
entire anti-riot arsenal including a
water cannon with chemical laced blue
dyed water but even though it's become a
routine and even though the protesters
will eventually get pushed out to some
it doesn't matter they say they will
keep showing up if I really have to care
about the success rate of the protesting
I never would have started to protest in
the beginning it's about our demands
after all we can't just keep silent and
let things happen the movement started
over a bill that would have allowed X
traditions from Hong Kong to mainland
China it was permanently shelved but the
movement grew and intensified mainly
because of what protesters have said is
the heavy-handed treatment by police as
they crack down on the protests and
unauthorized marches for the majority of
this unauthorized march through Central
Hong Kong here the protesters faced
little resistance from the police the
police were there but there really
wasn't any confrontation it was when
they got close to the government complex
here their final destination where there
have been kind of frontlines there's
been confrontation and then a push back
and then another frontline is they've
been established the police just on the
other side and that's one of the front
lines here on one side of the government
complex the show that protesters do not
represent all of Hong Kong's people a
pro-beijing group held two events across
the territory on Sunday a few hours
before the March began they sang the
Chinese national anthem
and in Taiwan viewed as a breakaway
province by Beijing a show of support
for Hong Kong people came out in the
pouring rain as part of what's being
described as a global
anti-authoritarianism day it's
anticipated that the Hong Kong
anti-government protesters will again
come out in force on Tuesday
it's China's National Day marking 70
years since the founding of the People's
Republic of China the protesters say
they will use the occasion to continue
their fight against what they say is
Beijing's move to gain more and more
control over their city
Scott hilar al Jazeera Hong Kong